jean gauthier a pris ce matin les
premiers ministres polonais tchèques et
slovènes se rendre à kiev aujourd'hui
qu'elle était de représentants du
conseil européen ce sont donc les
premiers représentants européens à se
rendre à kiev depuis le début de cette
guerre l'objectif c'est de rencontrer le
président ukrainien et son premier
ministre c'est un moment important donc
si je peux résumer ainsi oui c'est un
moment important mais même si il ya de
fortes chances qu'il ne reste que
symbolique dans la mesure où si l'europe
peut aider l'ukraine c'est aussi en
grande partie on le comprendra on en
comprendre la raison par des actions ou
des ouïes par des actions secrètes ou
confidentielles par exemple la livraison
d'armes dont on sait très bien qu'elle
ait d'abord problématique sur un plan
logistique mais aussi
sur un plan diplomatique ou politique
dans la mesure où il est évident que les
russes s'ils perçoivent ce type de
mouvement ne manqueront pas soin de les
annihiler mais aussi d'en
reporter la faute sur l'union européenne
et ne pas manqué de crier au loup en
disant que ce genre de d'action est de
nature à compliquer et aggraver le
conflit mais cette visite donc de
mateusz moi la vie est ce qui pour la
pologne pétel fiala pour la république
tchèque et ya les yaneshas pour la
slovénie est importante parce
qu'effectivement c'est une
représentation européenne tout à fait
officielle qui s'y rend avec d'ailleurs
même un certain nombre de risques et
peut-être il sans doute d'ailleurs que
le le cessez le feu qui a été décrétée
n'est pas étranger à cela puisqu'il
devrait permettre aussi que cette visite
se passe sans encombre
j'y vois une deuxième signification
vous remarquerez que ces trois premiers
ministres sont des premiers liste de
pays slaves et lorsque vous connaissez
l'obsession de vladimir poutine pour un
bon pour la slavophile i pour une forme
de ce l'habitude absolue qui confine à
une forme de supériorité raciale il faut
le dire ça n'est pas étranger même si ce
sont des slaves occidentaux que ces
trois personnes se rendent à kiev
d'abord pour témoigner leur soutien pour
voir ce qu'ils peuvent faire en
l'occurrence il s'agit par exemple la
pologne on vient de le voir dans le
reportage d'emmanuel chose qui prend
beaucoup passent en compte l'accueil de
réfugiés la slovénie évidemment vu sa
taille est un petit peu plus modeste
mais c'est intéressant pour cette raison
c'est aussi intéressant ce qui concerne
la slovénie dans la mesure où le premier
ministre gagne 0 ça a été un chef de
guerre de la défense territoriale
slovène dans les années donc en 1991
lorsque la slovénie a déclaré son
indépendance par rapport à ce qui était
la yougoslavie donc il y a aussi
peut-être j'allais dire des repas des
tuyaux ce serait indécent de dire ça
mais d une expérience commune de ce que
peut être une guerre profondément
asymétriques entre un faible bien fort
on a ces images dernière vous des
coulisses évidemment intenses
négociations tractations diplomatiques
des autorités ukrainiennes toujours
évidemment par visioconférence puisqu'il
reste cantonné à la capitale kiev qu'ils
n'abandonneront pas elle donne quoi
cette diplomatie aujourd'hui lé lien
direct entre les ukrainiens et les
russes et puis à tout ce qui se passe
autour et dont on ne parle pas forcément
alors oui c'est vrai que c'est compliqué
qu'elle peut elle peut paraître un peu
vaine cette diplomatie pour autant
d'abord je remarque depuis quelques
jours il y à des tonalités il ya des
échos plutôt positif de ces tractations
de ces pourparlers aussi bien d'ailleurs
côté ukrainien par la voix du président
volodymyr zelensky que deux du côté de
la russie puisque le le secrétaire de
presse de vladimir poutine dimitri
peskov a lui même dit qu'il y avait
peut-être un certain nombre de choses
dont on pouvait se réjouir à quoi ça
peut donc servir on a bien vu que sur
l'établissement de couloirs humanitaires
ça n'avait pas été vraiment une réussite
dans la mesure où la plupart ces
couloirs humanitaires atterrissait où
aboutissaient en russie ce qui était
pour des réfugiés ukrainien une chose
impensable en revanche là où ça peut
être utile c'est dans la mesure où on
sent que sur un certain nombre de points
qui étaient des points extrêmement de
discorde très forte avant l'invasion
russe c'est à dire par exemple
l'autonomie pour le dunk basse pour les
les régions donc les républiques
autoproclamées de donetsk et de lougansk
il semblerait que le pouvoir ukrainien
est assoupli sa position à tort ou à
raison peu importe mais que ça participe
de ces pourparlers est en revanche on a
assisté à un
un discours on a reçu un discours très
là aussi modifiée de la part des russes
puisque
je crois que c'est ma gaza rova qui a
dit que le but de la russie n'était pas
d'annihiler les tailles craignant ni
même de remplacer son pouvoir voyez
qu'il ya des dissonances dans la mesure
où vladimir poutine lui a toujours dit
qu'il fallait chasser donc les fameux
nazis ukrainien alors est ce que ça veut
dire qu'il y a un jeu au sens de du jeu
physique comme il ya un jeu dans une
porte ou dans dans une serrure entre le
pouvoir russe et ses négociateurs ça
n'est pas impossible
est-ce que de l'autre côté il y a la
volonté de calmer les choses oui c'est
calmé les choses mais c'est aussi gagner
l'assentiment de la communauté
internationale par lequel par laquelle
audi me gêne ce qui veut exprimer sa
bonne volonté dernier point en ce qui
concerne ce jeu éventuels qui aurait au
sein de la direction russe il est de
toute manière pour l'instant subordonnés
toujours et encore à l'assentiment de la
dîmière poutine vous avez bien vu que
même au niveau des ministres des
affaires étrangères quand les deux
russes et ukrainiens mise affaires
étrangères se sont rencontrés la
conclusion du ministre ukrainien était
de dire très bien on a discuté mais de
toute manière série lavrov doit toujours
rendre compte de ce qu'il dit à la
virgule près à vladimir poutine et donc
ça bloque un certain nombre
d'initiatives